elle s'est réjouit de la mort
d'Elizabeth II en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis cette vidéo la ville de
Jacky une restauratrice écossaise
opposée à la monarchie n'est plus la
même ils se sont déplacés par milliers
ont attendu des heures pour ces quelques
instants face à leur reine elle s'est
mise à dos les habitants de son quartier
pour preuve la devanture vandalisée de
son restaurant spécialisé dans les
chaînes chips et les scores policiers
nécessaires vendredi soir face à une
centaine de riverains en colère 15
minutes de recueillement
autour du cercueil de leur mère
et sous le regard des Écossais défilant
dans la cathédrale Saint-Gilles le
Conseil consultatif national des tiques
a pu l'idée d'une aide active à mourir
pour des patients dont le pronostic
vital est engagé un moyen terme le
cinéaste Jean-Luc Godard qui s'est
éteint à 91 ans ce mardi à eu recours à
l'assistance au suicide selon le
conseiller de sa famille le réalisateur
serait allé en Suisse pour cela Emmanuel
Macron n'exclut pas de s'inspirer de ce
modèle belge une consultation citoyenne
est lancée et pourrait aboutir à une
nouvelle loi sur la fin de vie l'an
prochain c'est très éthique sur les
conventions citoyennes mises en place
par le Président de la République celle
qui a été mise en place pour l'écologie
a été quand même un immense fiasco donc
je ne suis pas certaine de cette méthode
voilà je suis convaincu qu'il y a la
voix d'un débat apaisé et qu'on peut
avoir une très belle loi de consensus
pour y faire et faire évoluer ce droit
dans notre société de toute façon il ne
faut pas de loi ce sont des sujets qui
sont des sujets qui touchent à l'intime
si tentaient qu'il faille prendre des
décisions c'est au peuple français de
les prendre et à mon avis ça ne peut
passer que par l'intermédiaire d'un
référendum on a aujourd'hui de lobby qui
s'acharnent à empêcher cette ultime
liberté alors que eux sont respectés je
pense notamment évidemment au
responsables religieux et puis à
certains responsables des soins
palliatifs qui n'ont pas compris qui ne
seront obligés à rien puisque évidemment
une loi comme celle-là c'est une loi qui
respecte toutes les consciences et c'est
vrai qu'à un moment donné c'était vers
la fin de la première vague j'ai senti
que j'étais en zone de fragilité
c'est-à-dire j'ai senti les symptômes
qui ressemblent un burn-out j'en fais
des j'en ai fait beaucoup de diagnostics
c'est des malades avec les vertiges les
crampes la nausée l'incapacité de me
dire je vais réussir à rentrer dans
cette salle à l'Élysée m'asseoir et dire
ce que je dois dire et je me suis dit là
tu commences à tout petit peu attirer
sur la corde les habitants de
Saint-Etienne n'en n'ont pas fini avec
le scandale du chantage à la sextape le
site d'informations Mediapart a publié
hier des enregistrements audio
accablants pour le nerf qui perdrio à
ses côtés sont directeur de cabinet
Pierre gauthierry face à eux le premier
adjoint Gilles Artigues les menaces de
saisir la justice pour chantage il les
enregistre alors ainsi les propos sont
saisissants
des parents des élèves qui sont dans la
même classe que vous entendez une copie
du film le pouvoir et le cul ça n'est
pas une légende l'argent on peut
toujours dire ah mais non c'est pas vrai
une vidéo avec un escort gay
[Musique]